欸，你還記得幾年前，大家都在說AI會取代客服人員這件事嗎？那時候幾乎所有人都這樣預測。
當然記得啊，那時候報紙、新聞都在講，客服業會是AI時代第一個消失的產業。我還真以為以後打客服都只能跟機器人講話了。
對吧！但今天的這個創新案例，來自 Nikkei Asia 的報導，卻直接告訴我們，這個預測錯得有多離譜。AI不只沒有讓客服消失，反而讓它「文藝復興」了！
文藝復興？這怎麼說？難道大家現在更喜歡跟機器人聊天了？還是說AI變成幕後推手，但最終還是回到真人客服？
其實就是後者。原文直接點破，AI非但沒有取代人，反而讓「人」在客服中扮演了更關鍵的角色。它讓服務回歸人際連結的本質，甚至開創了服務業的新價值。
嗯，這點讓我有點詫異。一般公司導入AI，不就是為了降低人力成本嗎？如果AI最後還是要回歸人，那當初的大規模投資，真的划算嗎？難道他們覺得提升顧客滿意度就能彌補這些成本？
原文有提到一個關鍵點，就是「不是所有客戶接觸點都相同」。這句話很有意思。他們發現，其實大部分客服需求，像是「訂單在哪裡」、「怎麼重設密碼」、「可以更改配送日期嗎」，這些都是重複性高、情緒性低的例行性問題。
喔，所以這些才是AI能處理的？
對，這些正是AI擅長處理的部分。AI處理這些問題又快又準，甚至比人更有效率。顧客對於即時得到這些資訊，其實很少會覺得被怠慢。這就是把AI用在對的地方。
這麼說來，那真正的「人」該出現在什麼時候？難道只是處理那些AI處理不了的狀況嗎？
就是當情況變得複雜、牽涉到情感，或是需要信任感的時候。原文裡面引述了德國 Bitkom 在2025年的一項調查，針對線上購物者。結果發現，有62%的人遇到問題時，寧願找得到「人」來解決，只有36%的人會選擇聊天機器人。
62%對36%，這個差距可不小啊。所以當事情真的重要的時候，大家還是傾向跟真人溝通。
沒錯。而且，當顧客遇到問題，需要被理解的那一刻，如果得到的服務很差，這幾乎就決定了他們會不會繼續當你的客戶。所以，這正是人際連結的價值所在。
這點我是信了。不過，如果把AI用在例行公事，把真人用在複雜問題上，那客服人員的工作內容會不會變得更困難？他們要處理的都是棘手的問題，壓力會不會更大？
其實原文提到，AI反而讓人類客服的工作變得「不那麼繁瑣」。你想想看，客服人員一天的工作，有多少時間是花在搜尋資料、回溯舊信件、複製貼上，或是重複寫一樣的訊息？
嗯，確實不少。光是找資料可能就花掉大半時間了。
而這些，恰恰是AI最擅長的事情。AI接手了資訊檢索、摘要、和重複草擬的功能。它不是把人從對話中移除，而是把對話周圍的那些「苦差事」給移除了。這等於把時間還給了客服人員。
等等，這裡我有疑問。時間是還給客服人員了，但他們拿這些多出來的時間做什麼？真的是去「好好理解」客戶嗎？還是被公司要求處理更多案件，反而更累？
這就看公司怎麼規劃了。原文提到，當客服人員不必趕著結案時，他們就可以真正「傾聽」，去理解客戶真正打電話來的原因，安撫情緒焦躁的顧客，提供更深思熟慮的建議，並在最恰當的時機提供對的解決方案。
這樣聽起來，等於是把客服從一個「成本中心」，轉化成一個「成長引擎」了。
完全正確！當顧客覺得自己被理解、被「認識」時，這種感受在數位世界裡越來越稀有，但商業上的影響卻是巨大的。這就是交易和關係的差別。如果能好好處理，客服就能從一個需要最小化的成本，變成一個提升忠誠度、品牌形象和營收的槓桿。
我想到一件事，如果我是個小店老闆，沒有大型企業那種資源去開發複雜的AI系統，我該怎麼從這個概念裡學到東西？
其實原理是相通的。如果你是小店老闆，可能沒有資源自己開發AI，但你可以思考，有哪些重複性的工作，是可以透過現有的工具或服務來簡化，把你的時間省下來，去跟顧客建立更深層的連結。例如，用自動回覆處理常見問題，然後把精力放在那些需要你親自出場解決的客訴、建議或關係維護上。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念怎麼帶入自己的工作？
假設你每天都有很多重複性高、制式化的回覆或報告，可以思考有沒有現成的工具，或甚至透過自己設定的範本、腳本，讓AI幫你省下這些時間。然後，把省下來的時間，花在那些需要你展現「人味」、深入思考、需要協調和解決複雜問題的任務上。讓自己成為那個不可取代的「人」。
這樣看來，這其實是一個關於「如何把科技用在對的地方，讓人的價值最大化」的故事。不只是客服，很多產業或許都能這樣思考。
是啊，這點其實不容易做到。畢竟，原文也說了，科技很少是難點，但「架構」才是。如何正確地部署AI，需要有清晰的數據、明確的工作流程、好的提示語，以及對公司核心價值的理解。
聽起來，這好像也提醒了我們，在追求效率的同時，別忘了「人」的本質和價值。